how are you Mike well I'm doing good are
you doing we just had one of your
neighbors on here and Daler in our
junior he says hello no he's a nice guy
really hung out with him once but I hear
by him all the time I go to a bike shop
that's a right behind my shop or about
right behind my house and and Chris back
there sees everybody so he kind of keeps
me updated so but yeah he just I didn't
see the show but got a house built or
restored a house okay they did this show
on it oh I didn't know that they did a
show on that so they came in your house
with cameras and just to see what
doesn't mine
Oh his okay I see so yeah he said that
you and Chip Kelly were hanging out
that's what he said that he saw you
hanging out with Chip Kelly next door
yeah it was kind of funny we're Chip
Kelly was in town and kind of announced
and we'd always talked about because I'm
down there anyway and then chip had
always talked about coming down and so
I'm at this place that I hang out and
then all of a sudden in walks Chip Kelly
and so chipper then he spent time
together down there for a couple days
and then and then we go into another
place and there's Dale Earnhardt jr. so
when you when you have like when you're
running if someone like Chip Kelly
coached you do you talk ball is that
what you do or life or what is a
conversation you have with a with a
fellow offensive minded head coach yeah
we talk football some you know it's kind
of combinational talked with both some
talk livestock you know what he does in
the offseason that's at the thing really
all the above China okay so now let's
talk about your season a little bit here
you're heading to Colorado this week
what what is the challenge for you over
the next several weeks in your
estimation with the possibility of
winding up in the Final Four of the
college football playoff rankings
I think challenge really is always the
same was just uh just try to get better
each week try to focus on the present
and make the most of that because I mean
there's a lot of excitement I mean
obviously in our parter we wouldn't do
this but on the outside too and you just
got to kind of stay locked in and you
know stay excited about what you're
doing every day I think is really what's
most critical as your system meshed well
obviously with gardner minshew who's a
transfer this year how has that been in
terms of a transition for you I think
that's been probably the most impressive
thing that Gardner did is his ability to
integrate with our team as quickly as he
did and so you know we're going to have
a new quarterback and didn't have anyone
that did have a great deal of experience
and then so it's a three you know a
three-way race for our starting
quarterback and you know what I really
thought Gardiner did because he got he
didn't get here till the middle of May
and his but in the offseason the weight
room and all that really just kind of
became part of the unit and then and I
thought that was very impressive and
then the other thing is is and he'd
thrown the ball before and certainly
wanted to throw the ball but you know
just as far as being able to execute our
package with our players and picking it
up quickly and he had a presence about
him that lifted up the players around
him that I thought was really impressive
and as he's uh since he picked things
ups quicks he said I can't see was
necessarily the best physically out
there but he picked things up quickly
enough that I thought he would
be able to move the needle the farthest
over tide and you know if he had extra
time and I thought he could pick up
these mourn surpassed like so he has
done a really good job so if you could
wave a wand Mike Leach would you change
anything about the n-c-double-a transfer
rules at all or do you think that
they're fine the way that they are yeah
I'm not sure I think it's a little
disruptive with you know guys have a son
in the middle of the season you know
committed and they get you know they get
everything paid for then all of a sudden
have the ability to come in and say that
no I don't you know I don't want to be
on the team anymore you know I don't I
don't think that's a very good deal I
think that you know I died I like the
policy before were they you know he had
to get released could make a lateral
move so yeah because we're seeing around
the country kids who think that they
might not loot that they might lose a
redshirt year or able to to go to lose
or they lose a year if they transfer you
lose a year and you should mm-hmm so
here on our show where we're taking a
look at the way that the college playoff
rankings always maps out and I'm of the
mindset I'd like eight teams I'd like
eight teams in I'd like the five teams
from the so-called power five to get in
without a conference championship game I
think those conference championship
games are useless
and I'd like a regular season title to
lead to an automatic berth and then
three at-large bids and go and play on
Christmas weekend New Year's weekend in
the final weekend what would you say to
an idea like that
I think you'd definitely be an
improvement on what we have right now I
think that every conference you have
been that same number of conference
serve same number of conference games
I think either everybody has a
championship game or nobody does I think
that we definitely need more playoff
teams I've always thought you need at
least 16 and I would I'd rather see 64
but how would that work uh well you know
10 games in the regular season sets get
64 you go Kenyans in the regular season
so first off on the front end
everybody's guaranteed 12 games so you'd
have you'd have ten games in the regular
season and then and then as you're
getting towards the end the ten games
you have an idea it's gonna make the
playoffs and who's not and and so you
select who's gonna make the playoffs and
there will be natural breaks and the
thing so so in the course of the season
some were just a little over midway
through given half of the country's got
an off week the other half plays the
next week the other after country has
their off week and and nobody has to
play anybody where they had an off week
before the week before you play them and
then okay and so then 64 teams are
selected those that already know they're
not going to be selected can play that
week so that there's still football and
then you start out home and home and
like for example you see doubt the
region and a lot like basketball you see
doubt the region and then the lesser
seeded team goes to the higher seeded
team place in place after that you
integrate the bowls which there's
approximately things exactly the right
number to finish it out and then in the
end the champion will have played 16
games which I think that's the target
number because that's what the champion
in one double-a plays that's what the
champion in Division two plays that's
what the champion the champion in
Division three plays either 15 or 16 the
champion of most high school regions
play 16 and then Corsi NFL place more
and
I know I think everybody to have a
fabulous time I think it'd be exciting I
think that you know like right up the
road from us in Spokane is Gonzaga and
in basketball of course you go all over
the country and there's you'll run into
some rabid Gonzaga fan that one doesn't
know they're in Spokane and two doesn't
know where smoke is smoke in it and but
their Gonzaga fan because of the
exposure that they've gotten on you know
with the national tournament some things
so I think it'd be incredibly exciting
that they could help a lot of schools I
think you'd have a lot of variety of
whose claims you know around the country
and what what about final exams coach
yeah I get a kick out of that that's the
weakest argument of all of them Wow
well I mean what some kids at other
classifications like I school like
Division three like in Division two and
one double-a don't have final exams and
I mean most football an awful lot of
football in the postseason would take
place after finals anyway and then in
the least imposing on academics least
imposing sports on academics is football
I mean you consider a basketball
schedule baseball schedule a volleyball
schedule and I don't think they should
get rid of any of these sports because I
think sports for their own sake have a
value and I also think that you can do
both be graded academics and sports
including the ones I've mentioned but
you know football you leave the night
before you play the game and you fly
back and but yeah anybody that doesn't
want to change it or doesn't want the
hassle of doing it a different way or
doesn't even have the imagination of
whoever's running the parks and
recreation in their local community
that's drawing up tournament brackets
all the time so a little damage their
academics we'd never do it and they do
it in a very sanctimonious tone boys do
they always do it very sanctimonious
so the boys like they're the only ones
sensitive and they're the only one
should understand now that that to me is
the most absurd excuse that they try to
generate and they'll do it with such
piety - so then let me give you this
this other one that I hear all the time
when I try and give eight okay I'm
saying eight you're saying sixty you're
saying sixty-four like like hoops the
other one that I hear is that it would
remove the drama the win or go home
drama that seems to hinge on every
single week in the in the college
football season that I would remove that
like you know first of all they're
having games on concurrently if I'm
wrong because but I'll let see what days
I know Thursday and Friday and Saturday
hmm
so they have college games Thursday
Friday and Saturday they might have them
Wednesday - but it anyway people are
watching them I mean people watch all of
them and people are excited when they
watch them oh no there'd be I mean don't
you want continued role I like to you
know somebody's got a chance to redeem
themselves they lose one game I mean
what - drama - last to the end rather
than oh well alright that's it one loss
okay you know no I mean you know and
they're just just like we're discussing
here really I mean all they are is
excuses I mean I think everybody knows
that a bigger playoff format would
generate more money everybody knows it
would be exciting I think in the back
room the resistance is who would get the
money and who would have control of
things alright last one for you coach
since I've heard you give advice for
weddings and things like that do you
have any advice for Thanksgiving
families coming up sitting down together
different types of family members
different is there is there any sort of
parameters Mike Leach parameters that
you want to
posit to the American listening and
viewing public here to make life maybe a
little bit easier for Thanksgiving you
know I have to kind of abbreviated
Thanksgivings because we play that week
you know you play this running play in
practice that week so there will be one
for the players on earlier in the week I
forget it's either Tuesday or Wednesday
it depends whether we played Friday or
Saturday and then and we have that a
place called the zeppos which is a
fantastic place if you ever get up here
you certainly I would go okay
I also has a casino in the back room
around here we can do stuff like that
because you know we're up here in the
great white north and Viking country so
we can do whatever we want and then so
but they they serve the they serve the
turkey and you're just incredible job
it's it's like a sports bar bowling
alley nice so these guys are bold elite
they're Thanksgiving and then and then
of course there'll be the relatives
who've come home like no I don't know it
may not even be on Thursday this one
might be Wednesday but there will be a
second one going on at the house well I
mean I end up getting two of them but
all right and then often make the gravy
you're a gravy you make the gravy is
that your side of choice you know my
wife is developed into a better cook
than I am but the thing is is uh for
whatever reason she didn't know a lot
about making gravy and so for the last
couple decades I've been the gravy guy
you know you could say that about your
profession too much you know yes and you
got to put Tiger sauce in the gravy
what do you mean now there's a thing in
sort of a spicy sort of sauce thing with
in the grocery store about somebody in
Louisiana made it it's called tiger
sauce so I recommend you put that into
invest up your gravy Thank You coach
thanks for that a tip and for the whole
conversation always appreciate catching
up with you thanks to the call all right
thanks so much appreciate being on with
you
thank you you got a at coach underscore
leach on Twitter that's Mike Lee the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience